when people often think about innovation
and breakthrough products they often
imagine
secret labs in a hidden bunker working
away trying to solve a big problem open
innovation busts that paradigm it says
you're best suited to actually reveal
your secrets tell people what you're
working on and get the whole world to
work with you
but how could this even be possible how
could it be
that by telling the rest of the world
what you're working on that you can
still make a profit that you can still
be a successful company
open innovation has showed that the
constraint is not so much the ability
for you to keep things secret and to be
first to market the constraint is
solving problems being able to be first
in the market with the solution and
deploying it widely
and what open innovation allows you to
do is to not just reveal your secrets
that's not the point the point is to
engage with the outside world in the
strategic way that you can which allows
you to both preserve your secrecy but
also enable outsiders to work with you
this is the secret sauce of innovation
and why some of the top companies in the
world deploy without you
as a consumer ever knowing that the
products and services you're using are
based on open source
[Music]